ela era antes de começar a ouvir queria
falar pra você ter uma cidade chamada
betânia do piauí que tem várias crianças
lá é em estado de desnutrição e tem um
projeto que a gente fez para poder
arrecadar leite em pó para as crianças
se você é aquele teresina amanhã 19 de
janeiro seja até passar essa data que
não tem mais de 9 de janeiro às sete
horas da noite lá no teatro joão paulo
2º que além do bairro de seu é fica na
avenida principal perto do bob's o o
joão paulo 2º ano desceram a gente vai
fazer o standard saiu já que tenho um
humorista vai estar te ligo vai tá bom
mundo da àfrica uma galera lá para se
apresentar ea entrada são dois pacotes
de leite em pó que não precisa mais nada
dois pacotes de leite em pó tem mais
dinheiro que ajudar com mais mais leite
em pó leva mais para levar é 4 58 pacote
lei que possa você quiser leva quando
você quiser
a entrada só isso chegou lá dois pra cá
leite em pó entrou sem sua cadeira e é
nós esse vídeo foi o papa esse vídeo
está sendo pago no dia 8 olha aí o
calendário hoje é de 9 de janeiro 7 da
noite lá no teatro joão paulo 2o lado de
seu agente vai pegar todo esse leite foi
arrecadado vai levá-la para betânia do
piauí e vão distribuir lá atrás eu mesmo
então precisamos alimentar as crianças e
tirá la do dia da edição da espada de
negócio entre tam para se formar
direitinho primeiro link na descrição do
vídeo você clica e vai ter lá e aí você
se informa que ora é e tal chama sua
família seus amigos têm alguém quer me
conhecer e tirar foto tá lá é só não sei
lá eu estou a voltar lá vou fazer stand
up eu vou fazer nacional inédito e é
isso aí vamos lá vamos ajudar a galera
em maringá tam ea icann quer disputar só
é um ponto com e aí galera que assistir
o canal tudo bom com as senhoras e
senhores [ __ ] conselho não tem ideia é
o seguinte eu fui pra casa com a minha
casa nesse dia saí passei o natal ano
novo para chegar
você não tem idéia do mind pouco que
isso aqui tá é a dor que está entendendo
o doutô carvalho desarmônico vai
deixando de fumar no dia vai deixar
marca do dia para deixar de fumar e
pedia quando afeta 2014
então quase não foi arrumado nato de boi
fugindo conta única você não tem noção
de até gente mora no bairro são joaquim
e endereço da própria não peça dessa
câmera quinta o pm não sei por onde
barras negócio eu fui tirando a roupa e
foi entrando no meio foi entrando nessa
volta então eu falei não o paraná não
vai achar um negócio quando o cara tá na
cara da gente a mãe da gente ela sabe
ela bota tudo ela saúde bota é fácil mãe
cadeia um alfinete de dois gramas de
peso de três sentidos que eu perdi aqui
em casa fatah em cima da estante ao lado
dos livros na diagonal entre a televisão
e um dvd você vai lá um lugar set foi da
mãe da gente é [ __ ] e sabe que a
homenagem é [ __ ] porque a mãe da gente é
mulher porque se fosse homem eu tenho
certeza que não sabia todo mundo é eu
acho mulher é uma coisa perfeito no
catar em casa e te a mãe da gente lá ea
gente não sabe de uma coisa a gente vai
lá e pergunta à mãe da gente no catar
está resoluta o cara e o pai ele vai lá
no pai pergunta o pai aberta amanhã para
ligar para a mãe e perguntar pra ela
onde tal negócio porque tocou para os
habitats o pai é o meu pai não sabe um
homem não tem organização mulher tem um
é dois mulher né eu volte lagarce
silêncio no atacado não estaria morando
sozinho no meio da bagunça eu vejo a
falta que uma mulher fará a vida por um
homem pode falar um empréstimo ia me
cerquei a nem sei quem tentei e não
vives e mulher não vier a falar agora tá
aí é porque o cara de se evitar que as
mulheres melhor de tudo na nossa vida
não também não foi um sucesso e também
porque a mulher que ela reclama da dor
de uma cólica ela não sabe o que é
amizade paulo não vai você quer mulher
você fala que a mulher só
imagem a mulher faz isso que a mulher
faz aquilo e que o menino sofre na dança
vida 8 você em 2000 que ele já que o
negócio do nando europa onde manhã
quando a primeira espreguiçada e fácil
[Música]
além do cara tem que sair do quarto se
escondendo do mundo que não pode mostrar
gigante acordou ainda o cara chega no
banheiro e vai ter que se contorcer para
poder acertar no lugar do seu cd só leve
já de manhã que o negócio dele me
contratar porque ele pensa nós acrobacia
aí o cara aí o cara pega o negócio é
trabalho falei não é nova a gente domina
que sou eu o cara quer ser campeã o dono
que eu que sou o cara que eu sei fazer
uma obra minha vida ou num comércio como
não conhece ninguém não se aposte no
lugar que você tem que fazer negócio
para colocar o negócio para dentro do
vaso do carro seguro com firmeza na
pensão e mostra a face mesmo agora fará
na hora que ele só o cara 676 no meio do
relvado para certa pio lixeiro chuveiro
rápido banheiro melhor bola do vasco mas
é claro você que a mulher você também
tem que compensar seu falam que o homem
um salto que ele sofre agora uma coisa
que eu convidei por muito tempo da
mentira que eu achei que que a mulher um
ser que num não ser totalmente perfeito
é uma coisa que era assim nada de ruim
poderia sair da assembléia mas eu lembro
do dia na lenda o triste dia que eu
descobri que mulher pagador você não tem
né não lembro como se fosse hoje a moda
logo não perdeu a estrela do filho
drogba já tá fazendo esse banho de amor
de si tanto oo o eu tava kagan sabe que
mulher
kagan como é que é aquela coisa então eu
esteja aqui não falo sério que está
fazendo e espanha
nesse a pergunta que eu faço me montar
local pagando bem k grana
kagan 92
faltava o meu deus se amontoa quente
tempo tá mal pra que mesmo que eles têm
culpa aquele bem com ela na minha alma
gêmea e aí vai vê-la caga cara não vai
se abater o rebelde que nunca não jogou
aquilo foi informado na minha vida até
hoje estão fazendo terapia para poder me
controlar quando lembra que ela sim para
uma pessoa normal como você pode
carregar agora você dizer que apenas se
estiver quente perto cada de carro para
o mundo eu sempre tive um encanto
natural desde que eu comecei a aaa
a gostar de mim esse tipo encanto
natural problema depois que descobri que
mulher carga é pra mim é diminuir em 50%
enquanto a diminuir já que desperta
jogador pode pegar o papelzinho embalar
e vender que eu tenho certeza que a
cacau show 2 ou k2 noite eu falo pra mim
que ia sair daqui sem falar que nesse
vídeo nando e papai que essa espada
então o não deixe jóias para nós que
isso é muito importante para crescer
a primeira vez que está dando uma olhada
no vídeo no canal clique inscrever se
tem aqui o tucano escrever se não
estiver o piloto vai saber de alguns
vídeos no canal pode assistir passo que
lá é isso vai dar ou não vai
são paulo se você for um nome eu quero
que você comente aqui embaixo que você
acha mais engraçado e estranho nas
mulheres se você como mulher eu quero
que você comente aqui embaixo que você
acha mais estranho ou engraçado nos
ombros brigar por ter chance veio até
aqui vocês são show de bola é nóis nas
redes sociais tudo aqui na descrição do
vídeo no facebook o meu twitter não
estraga tudo aqui na descrição do vídeo
é só você olhar e na e3